Sandrine et qu'on
[Musique]
applaudit tu aimes bien manger oui
qu'est-ce que tu aimes le mieux ben
j'aime le Cassou ah dans le Nord oui
surtout bah c'est normal qu et puis
parce que quand maman
fait du Cassou ben moi je fais toujours
la
nuit tu fais je fais toujours la
nuitand Saou qu'est-ce que tu fais la
nuit je fête
ah bon oui pourquoi
va va fait péter
[Musique]
unouet ça c'est marrant c'est pour ça
que tu aime le souet parce que ça fait
péter
oui j'y penserai quand
même et ça c'est marrant
oui il y a que toi qui s arrive dans la
famille hein il y a que toi à qui ça
arrive dans la famille non qui est-ce
qui pète encore
papa
crristelle c'est une famille qui
pte tu vas à l'école ouais tu manges à
la cantine ou tu manges chez maman je
mange beaucoup à la cantine et puis je
mange un petit peu chez Maman et à la
cantine qu'est-ce qu'on mange on
mange toujours
un non moi je fa du cassoulet du
cassoul soleil était haut c'était
l'après-midi